Being Wednesday, there are more questions
for New York
Republican Congressman George Santos,
including about the $700,000
he previously claimed
he lent his campaign,
but apparently not anymore.
New FEC filings suggest he did not.
Then there were his recently
uncovered claims
that he was mugged
in 2021 in broad daylight on Fifth Avenue
here in New York,
and that the muggers even stole
his shoes, he says.
Also, his claims
that he survived an attempt on his life,
although he didn't want to talk about it
today with CNN's Manu Raju
Why don't you file a police report
about your
assassination attempt
that allegedly happened?
What about being mugged?
Why don't you file
a police report about that?
Sorry,
I have not
I haven't heard from a single four year
No real answers
from the congressman on those questions
about his claims.
There is nothing, though,
absurd about campaign finance.
Is concerned.
CNN's Jessica Dean
joins us now
with more on his answers about that.
So what did Congressman Sanders
have to say about these amended
FEC reports?
Well, Anderson,
as you can imagine,
not a ton of answers
coming from the congressman today.
And just to catch everybody up.
He had previously said
that he personally
loaned his campaign
some $700,000
just a little bit over that.
Well, then they amended these FEC
filings recently,
just in the past several days.
And there are two loans,
one for about $500,000,
another for about $125,000.
And the part where you would mark
that it comes from personal funds
is now not marked.
So that's the big change.
And there's been a lot of questions
about where that money came from
in the first place.
And now this change in. Was it personal?
Was it not?
Our colleague
Manu Raju asked him about this as well.
And I'll let you see how that one
Why did
you amend your FEC reports to say $500?
Let's make it very clear.
I don't have anything.
I don't touch any of my FEC stuff. Right.
So don't be disingenuous.
And report that I did,
because you know
that every campaign hires a fiduciary.
So I'm not aware of that answer.
And we'll have an answer for the press
regarding the amendment from yesterday.
And just remember,
he often likes to tell the press,
tell us, Anderson,
that he'll be talking to us
in the coming days,
but he'll have answers tomorrow.
And that has been going on
now for weeks and weeks and weeks.
And also important
to remember that
he really pushed this off
on fiduciaries on others,
that it was not him
that made these changes
or was responsible.
And I understand
a political treasurer
is saying that the Santos campaign
listed him as overseeing
their political accounts
without his authorization. Right.
And so that's
why it's so important, right.
That he's
pointing to these others
that are responsible for this,
because now we're learning
that this Wisconsin based
political treasurer is saying
who is listed on
these reports,
is saying through a lawyer,
but he never agreed to be listed
as his treasurer,
treasurer to act as his treasurer.
So this is obviously a giant discrepancy.
This lawyer
telling CNN that they had a conversation
with Santos representatives on Monday
saying they would not agree
to serve as a treasurer.
And yet there is what this lawyer
is calling a disconnect
between that conversation
and what got filed in these FEC reports.
And, Anderson,
to your point from earlier,
you just don't mess around
with these federal documents
if you are caught lying on these.
That is a very, very serious
federal crime.
Speaker McCarthy
discussed the Santa situation
in a closed conference meeting today.
Do we know anything about that?
What he said, we don't.
Yeah, we know a little bit. So these are.
This is their conference meeting
that they have
where they all come together.
And we do
know, based on sources in the room
that he did talk a little bit about this.
But the bottom line that he said is
there is a difference between lying
and committing a crime
and committing a crime is what gets
you kicked off your committees.
And he reiterated this public stance
that he's had again and again,
which is the voters.
It's up to the voters.
They put him into office.
It's up to the voters
ultimately to get him out of office.
He did say earlier this week, Anderson,
that if he is found
by the Ethics
Committee
to have committed a crime,
that he would be removed.
But that's going to take a very long time
for that process
to even play out at this point.
He's going to stay on here in Congress.
And as we know, he's
been assigned to a couple of committees
and the work will continue for them.
So the lies are okay, just not a crime.
Just get in.
Thanks very much.
To help understand
how Republicans in the House
are approaching
all this, we're joined now by former
Illinois Republican Congressman
Joe Walsh.
He's currently
host of the White Flag Podcast.
Congressman Walsh,
thanks for being with us.
Of course, the
the board
I mean, it's
it seems a complete mess with Santos.
How does this compare to other
ethically challenged liars? You've seen
Well,
Anderson, that's such a great question.
Look, this should matter.
His FEC filings should matter.
It looks like an
there ought
to be an FEC full investigation
or a full audit.
It looks like there are major FEC
violations here.
But will that matter?
To Kevin McCarthy and House Republicans?
Anderson,
I doubt it,
because we now know
the line doesn't matter.
The line doesn't matter at all
in the line Does it matter in this party?
For a lot of reasons, Anderson.
But we have to keep reminding ourselves
that the leader of this party remains
Donald Trump.
And so it's really difficult
for Republicans
to penalize another Republican for lying
when Donald Trump is its leader.
Regarding the FEC and finance laws,
I mean,
we're the are the punishments for that
all that severe
I mean, are they financial or are they.
Is it
really anything to be concerned about
Typically, not typically.
FEC violations can be a slap
on the wrist, Anderson,
to members of Congress.
But looking at what Santo said, my God,
these are the sloppiest filings
we've ever seen
or there's some real campaign
finance fraud going on here.
I want to play
Kevin McCarthy is the speaker.
Anderson, he
he needs
all he cares about is remaining speaker.
And so he's
not going to do anything to Santo
unless literally there are serious
financial crimes he's committed.
I want to play something
that Speaker
McCarthy said last night
about restoring integrity to the House
Intelligence Committee.
Vote by stripping
committee assignments
away from certain Democratic
This is not
anything political.
This is not similar
to what the Democrats did.
But integrity matters
and they have failed in that place.
From Adam Schiff,
using a position of the intel
chair, lying to the American public
again and again,
I wonder, what do you make of that?
I mean, it's interesting, him
calling out lie.
What he says relies on that.
In that case,
listen, when I listen to McCarthy there,
it just doesn't
it doesn't sound like him.
I served with McCarthy.
That's that's not him.
I think Kevin McCarthy knows
that what he's doing to Adam
Schiff and Swalwell is.
But McCarthy has no choice
because he won't be speaker
if he's not seen
as fighting these fights.
And we make a big mistake on TV
and in the media
when we think that there are only 15
to 20
mega extremists in the House
Republican Conference.
Remember, the vast
majority of that conference is now mega.
The vast
majority of House
Republicans are election deniers
or January 6th sympathize hears
McCarthy doesn't
have just a couple crazies
like Lauren Boebert to deal with.
It's his whole conference.
Joe Walsh,
I appreciate your time tonight.
Thank you.